martin biron hélène buzzati michel david
bonsoir et notre collègue d'ottawa
louise blouin qui est avec nous parce
que louis vous avez écrit un texte qui a
attiré notre attention sur les frais
d'avocats de madame la gouverneure
générale à tahoua pas cette histoire là
n'est pas terminée oui ça continue
patrice et le bureau de la gouverneure
générale confirme avoir dépensé 110
mille dollars jusqu'ici d'argent public
en frais d'avocats dans la foulée de cet
examen est terne du climat de travail à
rideau hall on sait que red one est
secoué par une crise depuis ces derniers
mois l'ancien juge michel bastarache de
la cour suprême qui agit à titre de
conseiller constitutionnel auprès de la
gouverneure générale empocher jusqu'à
l'est jusqu'à maintenant trente six
mille dollars
la prestigieuse firme d'avocats blix
aussi en poche et 74 mille dollars juste
ici pour accompagner conseiller le
bureau la gouverneure générale dans cet
examen du climat de travail examen
indépendant qui se déroule actuellement
facture qui pourrait continuer de
grimper patrice au bureau du gouverneur
général
on explique qu'il ya pas de conseillers
juridiques alain interne pour conseiller
la gouverneure générale c'est ce qui
justifierait d'aller chercher des
services comme ça à l'extérieur et on
dit que cet examen du climat de travail
soulève aussi des questions légales et
constitutionnelles
alors c'est comme ça qu'on justifie tout
ça et j'ajoute un élément d'information
karl bélanger ancien directeur national
du parti nouveau du nouveau parti
démocratique a aussi été embauché par la
gouverneure générale pour sa gestion de
crise cet été alors que le bureau de
madame payet devait gérer la toutes les
retombées négatives de ces allégations
d'un climat de travail toxiques mais
monsieur bélanger lui a obtenu un
contrat jusqu ici de moins de 5000 $
pour conseiller en matière de
communication stratégique man en
paillettes dans la foulée de cette crise
da alors des factures qui s'accumulent
luigi en terminant et à quel moment on
aura le fruit de cette enquête là qu'il
a fait rappeler nous on a mal le conseil
privé donc le mystère du 1er mai sont
mandaté une firme privée pour faire
enquête et à quand les résultats
on nous dit que ce rapport là doit être
rendue cet automne on n'a pas de détails
précis sur l'échéancier et à savoir
aussi si toutes les révélations seront
rendus publics
tout ça je le rappelle a été commandé
par le gouvernement
le bureau du conseil privé on attend
tout ça avec everest louis merci de
votre visite merci nous avons ramené
cette nouvelle saveur nous on va partir
de là dessus et leur budget ti bonsoir
je vous donne la parole
bon elle se défend en fait je conte
souligner par cette histoire là c'est
que c'est l'ombre puis ça peut être long
et pénible pour beaucoup de monde ça
peut aussi moi je pense que deux façons
de comprendre cette information d'une
part ça peut vouloir dire qu'elle a
l'intention de s'accrocher à son poste à
vouloir comme ceux dotés de services
pour l'aider et il faut comprendre que
c'est très difficile de se débarrasser
d'un gouverneur général j'ai fait
quelques vérifications et en fait ce que
le premier ministre peut faire au mieux
c'est de lui chuchoter à l'oreille qu'on
aimerait bien qu'elle s'en aille
on n'a pas le pouvoir de la de la
congédier si on veut faire ça il faut
passer par la reine en grande bretagne
ça peut engendrer une crise
constitutionnelle monarchique dont le
gouvernement n'a peut-être pas très
envie en ce moment j'ai eu des
spécialistes qui disait dans tout comme
un noël c'est arrivé seulement trois
fois dans l'histoire qu'on a congédié
des gouvernants général une fois sainte
lucie et l'autre fois à cinq quitte donc
ça peut vouloir dire ça mais ça peut
aussi juste refléter la nature des
allégations ont ce sont des gens à
l'interné qui attaquent madame payet est
donc peut-être qu'elle ne se sent pas en
confiance de livrer sa stratégie avec
des gens qui sont peut-être ces
accusateurs welsh elle d'avis parce que
vous croyez que ce truc doit chuchoter
dans l'oreille de madame payet que
peut-être pas là mais un jour bientôt
peut-être le temps sera venu de passer à
quelqu'un dont monsieur trudeau lui-même
ça me surprendrait beaucoup mais je
serais pas surpris que quelqu'un d'autre
du bureau de monsieur trudeau où watsco
dans l'entourage plus ou moins proches
lui et lui ai suggéré de réfléchir
disait mais ce qui me dérangeait un
peuple ce qui reste de chicoter c'est
que ces frais là sont engagés par madame
payet dans le fonds pour sauver sa job
c'est pas la demande pas des conseils
lauda pour pour prendre une décision de
nature conditionnelle comme par exemple
quand jean-michel gens avaient dû ni
plus ni moins mitri entre eux monsieur
harper qui voulait prorogé la session
parce qu'ils risquaient d'être renversée
et l'opposition qui auraient voulu avoir
de nouvelles élections ou ont formé une
coalition
c'est pas la même chose ces frais là
dont les frais des contribuables aux
frais des contribuables
ils sont cent de moins
comment dire les justiciables auprès de
la population que si c'était une
décision dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions qu'elle avait à prendre dont
martin au plus vite leur quête les
résultats qu'on sache exactement qu'on
compte qu'on voit clair mais je pense
comme hélène qu'elle s'accroche parce
que sinon elle n'aurait pas besoin de
tous ces conseils là et du côté de
monsieur trudeau je pense que dans une
situation où il n'y a pas vraiment un
choix de deux de gérer la crise en
essayant de la rente pas trop visible
souvent mais c'est visiblement parti en
vrille cette histoire là alors oui
effectivement vivement les résultats
d'une enquête
alors oui oui j'allais dire qu'il ya pas
de problème monsieur trudeau aussi parce
que outre les employés de rideau hall
qui se plaignent anonymement
il ya eu d'autres reportages et
stylistique font état d'un même de
problèmes similaires dans ses deux
précédentes d'emploi notamment au centre
des sciences de montréal qui est dirigée
par une société de la couronne et une
personne là bas a confié je pensais à 6
by side
c'est bizarre quand monsieur trudeau a
songé à la nommer il ne peut pas appeler
chez nous pour savoir si on avait des
récriminations particulière alors
peut-être que toute cette histoire aussi
voir finir par faire mal à monsieur
trudeau pour en mettant en lumière le
fait qu'on n'a peut-être pas fait toutes
les vérifications nécessaires et que on
aurait su que si on avait appelé qu'il y
avait peut-être potentiellement un
problème
avec madame payet peut plus rien
attendre à courir mais ça fait quand
même beaucoup de monde qui va mettre la
lutte il fait vous dit qu'il y aurait
dit elle n'est pas facile parce qu'il
faut faire la différence entre quelqu'un
d'exigeant est quelqu'un qui est
tellement exigeant que sarah les autres
employés vraiment mal à l'aise et un
malaise lecteurs c'est ça alors c'est
tout l'équilibré
on le sait il ya plusieurs histoires de
cette nature-là faut être prudent quand
même parce que bon mais quand même à ce
choix c'est un choix alors il a choisi
une vedette
nous ici on a eu lise thibault qui a
marqué l'imaginaire qui avait été qui
était handicapée qui a été poursuivi est
trouvé coupable de fraude et d'abus de
confiance
le mandat suivant c'était quelqu'un
d'assez âgée qui a été nommé lieutenant
gouverneur et qui était assez belge on
voulait pas avoir pas trop de regrets
c'est ça très bien
non nationale on y revient en sièges et
celle des jeux je vous ferai pas
entendre les extraits d' hier mais je
veux vous entendre là dessus parce que
c'est loin d'être terminé
martin à québec quand monsieur legault a
dit monsieur trudeau joue avec le feu
est ce que vous croyez qu'il en a encore
derrière lui d'abord le même consensus
qu'il avait il ya un mois des autres
premiers ministres qui ne veulent pas de
condition qu'ils veulent que leur
système de santé soit mieux financiers
monsieur legault ne laisse pas passer
urnes parce que monsieur dec monsieur
trudeau 100 pur
dire des les transferts en santé dire
que des normes qui veut des conditions
attachées au financement
monsieur legault sort du tac au tac et
c'est presque c'est devenu récurrent
alors oui les champs de compétence du
québec je pense qu'au québec on est la
classe politique est unanime et je pense
que l'ontario et les provinces de son
côté les discussions pour les transferts
en santé ne sont pas commencé mais c'est
ce que la pandémie a quand même donné
certaines munitions au gouvernement
fédéral
monsieur legault en ayant recours à
l'armée
ça a été difficile pour monsieur le goût
de faire appel au fédéral pour l'aider
dans les chu cd pendant la pandémie et
il le paye peut-être un peu à ce moment
ci dans le discours et il est pris aussi
avec une avec une grande beaucoup de
gens en fait dans la population au
québec sont fantastiques critique par
rapport à la gestion du gouvernement du
québec dans les ch et celle des et ça
rend les choses plus compliquées c'est à
dire que monsieur legault va devoir
aussi faire des gestes pour améliorer la
situation dans les résidences pour les
personnes âgées
ça c'est clair que ici les gens
heureusement on le souhaite vont vont se
souvenir de ce qui s'est passé
donc ça ne se reproduise plus à
hellemmes buzzati comme ce truc
qu'est ce que monsieur trudeau à en-tête
d'un prêt vous parce que ça n'allait pas
interrompre une condition s'apprête il a
cinq ou six oui j'avoue que je n'ai pas
réussi à se faire confirmer ce qu'ils
avaient précisément en fait et ce qu'il
voulait faire mais on pense que ça peut
ressembler à ce qu'on a vu dans le passé
on fixe un certain niveau minimal de
ressources de services pardon en
contrepartie de l'obtention de
ressources
je pense que ce positionnement de
monsieur trudeau est de nature à plaire
à son allié du jour le npd qui n'a pas
souvent fait la distinction entre les
juridictions fédérales et provinciales
le jour je rappellerai que monsieur jobs
meeting avait lancé la campagne
électorale fédérale l'année dernière en
promettant l'ouverture la construction
d'un hôpital alors et je pense que c'est
nature à plaire ou 1 [ __ ] mais chassez
d'accord avec martine que un grand
nombre de provinces ont très
certainement les plus grandes
robin ayant été le plus touché par la
pandémie le je pense ici à l'ontario et
l'alberta sont susceptibles de ne pas
être d'accord avec ça dans le discours
du trône n'y avait même pas de mention
quant à l'augmentation des transferts en
santé alors monsieur trudeau a un peu
perdu la carotte éventuels avec laquelle
il aurait pu faire passer ces normes
nationales alors je ne sais pas trop
comment il va s'y prendre
peut-être qu'il va en appeler
directement la population pour mousser
leur frustration par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé mais au québec
je pense que les gens comprennent assez
bien les distinctions oui je pas
certaine que ça va fonctionner ouais
comme envoyer les prochains mois michel
david un sujet là ben il est clair que
monsieur le good et est agacé de voir
monsieur trudeau qui donne l'impression
de vouloir profiter de la pandémie pour
pour empiéter sur les pouvoirs des
provinces à cet ourson l'agenda
centralisateur qu'on reproche aux
gouvernements fédéral et en particulier
ou libéraux les provinces l'expérience
nous enseigne que les fronts communs des
provinces s'est passablement fragiles
alors on a vu plusieurs fois où toutes
les provinces semblaient d'accord pour
s'opposer à des intrusions fédéral est
finalement gouvernement fédéral de
négocier et québec s'est retrouvée
finalement tout seul dans son coin et il
ya toutes sortes de petits signes qui
j'imagine doivent agacé monsieur que
vous prenez par exemple annoncé la
semaine dernière la ministre de la santé
réfléchit c'est tout haut à la
possibilité de
comment dire d'appliquer la loi sur la
santé au test de dépistage qui sont
confiés à des laboratoires privés
isabella c'est peut-être une entorse au
principe de la loi canadienne sur la
santé mais qu'il faudrait pénaliser les
provinces et à font appel à des
laboratoires privés
alors il ya toute sorte de piscine comme
ça qui je comprends et agace monsieur
legault
monsieur legault bon on termine sur pied
ça va être long ces négociations
probablement pas d'ici les prochaines
élections
non mais on sent qu'ils ont un agacement
de part et d'autre part tu es aussi
québec lever le nez au départ sur les
téléphonistes de statistique canada mise
à leur disposition pour faire du votre
stage de contacter le rejet de
l'application alerte kobe dans un
premier temps qu'on a fini par adopter
mais à ottawa je peux vous dire qu'on a
un certain agacement on va à une
attitude de québec consent comme
rébarbative à tout ait fédéral même mais
quand monsieur trudeau dit qu'il va par
exemple en paix comme le type de normes
l'aï dit on pourrait empêcher le
mouvement de personnel entre les ch et
cd on est vraiment presque dans la micro
gestion là c'est presque dans on va vous
montrer comment faire des horaires alors
c'est sûr que pour monsieur legault ça
devient comme c'est ingérable ça va
devenir extrêmement compliqué surtout si
on commence à préciser clairement
spécifiquement le type de façon dont on
a vu que le ch et celle des soies gérer
un petit mot sur le parti québécois nous
avions le chef hier en entrevue là
aujourd'hui il annonçait un conférence
de presse sur qui va faire quoi martin
qu'est ce qu'on doit retenir de la
journée
kiki qui commence un mandat qu'il est
assez néophytes là il arrive dans les
souliers de chef n'a jamais siégé à
l'assemblée nationale
et ça passera pas facile dans son caucus
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont pas mal
plus d'expérience que lui il ya opté
pour un certain statu quo mais ça ne
sera pas facile aussi avec les autres
partis parce qu'elle dit aujourd'hui je
veux m'installer à l'assemblée nationale
je veux être présent l'assemblée
nationale se doit de donner un bureau à
nelu là il n'est pas élu et expliqué
bérubé va rester pascal bérubé et
demeure le chef parlementaire qui a
réussi à les convaincre de garder un
certain statut cool pour que ça
fonctionne quand même à partir de la
semaine prochaine celle david là dessus
c'est vrai mais je pense que la décision
de convaincre monsieur bérubé de rester
en place l'été était la meilleure que
monsieur s'inquiète le monde on pouvait
prendre s'ils avaient par exemple
confier ça à un autre député passe de
toute évidence six étapes intéressait ce
que ce soit sylvain gaudreault son
adversaire principal dans la course qui
occupe le poste
et s'il avait confié un troisième député
là ça aurait été encore plus difficile à
prendre pour monsieur gaudreault temps
dépassé bérubé y était là il fait
consensus au sein de son équipe et il a
fait un très bon travail au cours des
deux dernières années
alors ça ça passe relativement bien
pour le reste j'ai hâte de voir moi
d'abord ce qui va confier un second de
route j'imagine que ce monsieur voudront
veut garder l'environnement à monsieur
st pierre plamondon va se faire un
plaisir de lui laisser
mais gérard d'avoir aussi la motivation
de monsieur godeau au cours des
prochains mois et je peux pas m'empêcher
de penser à ce qui est arrivé alexandre
cloutier au lendemain de la dernière
course il était favori jean françois
lisée avait gagné et monsieur on l'a vu
tout de suite monsieur monsieur cloutier
avait avait perdu la motivation et
finalement il a complété son mandat mais
sans grand enthousiasme
voilà bon ben c'est pas mal ça pour ce
soir merci beaucoup de nous parler on se
retrouve hélas nous sommes heureux de
vous avoir retrouvé 11 est gérable
toujours un plaisir et c'est parfait
merci à vous trois très bientôt